neprino suffered the loss now johnny
works for the world's worst boss
yeah when water's assistance became my
prize there was terror in his eyes
earlier this month i graced an odd show
called jesse waters prime time
i faced off against dana in a game
called sink or swim initially dana won
but she failed the drug test
i kid the prize win jesse's assistant
johnny for a day i was hoping for the
set of steak knives but you take what
you can get it was a tense battle but
like me at hot mail model camp i fully
dominated we are presenting you
johnny for a day really my assistant
will be your assistant for a day wait
did i approve this ah this is great and
you can you can do whatever you want
with them i am cashing in on this and
the things i'm going to do to him i
can't even tell you on television hr h
oh hr will never if he even returns your
lunch is going to be amazing
he's going to be my lunch
man on the street about jessica that's
i'll make him no no you're not going to
make him make him work thank you guys
very much thanks for having us so i bet
many people including jesse didn't think
i'd cash in
on my prize
but i did
here's how we violated several new york
labor laws plus a few laws of human
decency
yeah
yeah hello greg
look who showed up
you know just three minutes early you're
actually late if this is what you're
gonna wear
i've got a lot of work for you to do all
right
he's here
uh
uh don't worry about that
don't worry about it you're here to work
not to judge
no judging come on in you little freak
his life's over
this is just another normal day at my uh
my house um i'm gonna have you do some
lighthouse work perhaps some any kind of
uh needs that my guests have
uh just a couple of people
uh he doesn't speak just have a secret
can you have a seat right there please
sure all right excellent put my helmet
there take this thing oh
would you care for a crawler oh you know
no thank you that's good because you're
not eating on the job
okay
so
i have your files
you know what's in your file this
i won you for the day
on jessie water's show after beating
dana preno you know what else is in this
file nothing
that means there are no restrictions to
what i can
ask maybe we should call jesse and see
if there's any jessie can i help you
right now he's turned off his phone
it's just you and me and my desires
so let's get started i think my kayaks
need cleaning
and that's not a euphemism
[Music]
kayak season johnny
yeah been sitting here for a couple of
months now they need some cleaning
unfortunately all i could find
was this toothbrush
so here you go uh
it looks like it's gonna get dark soon
so i'd probably get started uh with just
this yeah just this and uh good luck
with it i'll be upstairs uh don't
disturb me if it looks like i'm being
disturbed
harder
[Music]
clean clean like your life depended on
it because it does
i was thinking that it's really hard
because like i am so smart but i'm also
so pretty so because i'm so smart people
don't realize how pretty i am because of
how pretty i am people notice how smart
i am
finally you're doing some real work
so uh
while you're down there can i ask you to
do something for me sure greg can you
tell me does this look infected
[Music]
yeah baby
faster let's go harder
i gotta beat my personal back
what are you doing down there
back in a second guys gotta hit the john
that's a lot of sausage
jesse we're gonna have to change this
game show prize this has been really
crazy i don't know what else he's gonna
make me do
johnny you got to come and look at this
[Music]
[Laughter]
i should ask you tyrus don't talk to
me nothing i got
nothing to say nothing
nothing to say
just
wow man
wow i did fulfill the obligation yeah
you did you did is where is he is he
okay i don't know if he ever came back
no nobody get back uh cat i
do you think he did a full work full
day's work yeah i think he did a great
job i mean the day got weirder
got very weird
it got a lot weirder yes it did um but
none of that after the cameras left yeah
we had some great cameos walter kern and
tom chalu yes and your and keith and
keith of course keith was there eating a
lot of hot dogs a lot of hot dogs that's
just his little shorts it's just wow i
think it's funny that we're treating
this like a sketch and not the actual
documentary that it was
that was a sketch that was
you know the scene in boogie nights with
sister christian when they're throwing
snaps that's gut felt that was you that
was this premise
but i couldn't find a young man to throw
firecrackers around me the only thing
i can add is nice calves oh very nice
you know that's peloton
you don't think they're nice calves i
just i just saw you go like this
you shouldn't say bad stuff about his
calves
no you know what too late kinky lady
i feel dirty and wonderful hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else